does any part of you feel relieved you  don't really have to hide everybody  knows Spider-Man but in my life was  perfect when you found out you both like  each other we get it hang up I need my  eight hours have you been listening this  whole time not by choice  can we just like stay up here all day it  is so crazy down there  let's see  hello Peter do I know you you think your  fancy new suit's Gonna Save You  looks like we got competition  what's happening they're starting to  come through and I can't stop them well  you're thinking I'm about to do  something that could break the universe  I know you run it by us we need to send  them back  [Music]  you're flying out into the darkness to  fight ghosts what do you mean they all  die fighting Spider-Man I'm sorry kid  yeah me too don't  there has to be another way there isn't  Spider-Man no way home December 17th